so what's your intuition here you had a
conversation
with sam harris recently that was uh
sort of um
you've had a bit of a disagreement
you're sticking on this point
you know elon musk stuart russell
kind of have us worry existential
threats of ai what's your intuition why
if we engineer an increasingly
intelligent neuro cortex type of system
in the computer why that shouldn't be a
thing that we
it was interesting we used the word
intuition and sam harris used the word
intuition too and
and when he used that intuition that
word immediately stopped and said oh
that's the cut of the problem
he's using intuition i'm not speaking
about my intuition yes
i'm speaking about something i
understand something i'm going to build
something i am building
something i understand completely or at
least well enough to know what it's all
i'm guessing i know what this thing's
going to do and
i think most people who are worried
they have trouble separating out they
don't have they don't have the
knowledge or the understanding about
like what is intelligence how is it
manifest in the brain how is it separate
from these other functions in the brain
and so they imagine it's going to be
human-like or animal-like it's going to
have it's going to have the same sort of
drives and emotions we have but there's
no reason for that
that's just because there's there's an
unknown if you're if the unknown is like
oh my god you know i don't know what
this is going to do we have to be
careful it could be like us but really
smarter
i'm saying no it won't be like us it'll
be really smart but it won't be like us
at all
and um and but i i'm coming from that
not because i'm just
guessing i'm not into it using intuition
i'm basically
like okay i understand this thing works
this is what it does let me explain it
to you
okay but uh to push back so i also
disagree with the the intuitions that
sam has
but but i also disagree with what you
just said
which you know what's a good uh analogy
so if you look at the
twitter algorithm in in the early days
just recommender systems you can
understand how recommender systems work
what you can't understand in the early
days is when you apply that recommender
system at scale to thousands and
millions of people
how that can change societies yeah so
the question is yes you're just saying
this is how
an engineer neurocortex works but the
que
like when you have a very useful uh
tick-tock type of service that goes
viral when your neural cortex goes viral
yeah and then millions of people start
using it cannot destroy the world
no uh well first of all this is back one
thing i want to say is that uh
ai is a dangerous technology i don't i'm
not denying that all technology is
dangerous well an ai
maybe particularly so yeah okay so um
am i worried about it yeah i'm totally
worried about it the the thing where the
narrow component we're talking about now
is the existential risk of ai
right so i want to make that distinction
because i think ai can be applied poorly
it can be applied in ways that you know
people are going to
understand the consequences of it um
these are all potentially very bad
things
but they're not the ai system creating
this existential risk on its own
and that's the only place i disagree
with other people right so so i
i think the existential risk thing is um
humans are really damn good at surviving
so
to kill off the human race it'd be very
very difficult you can even yes but you
can even i'll go further i don't think
ai systems are ever going to
try to i don't think ar systems are ever
going to like say
i'm going to ignore you i'm going to do
what i think is best
i don't think that's going to happen at
least not in the way i'm talking about
it
so you the twitter recommendation
algorithm this interesting example
let's let's use computers as an analogy
again right
i build a computer it's a universal
computing machine i can't predict what
people are going to use it for they can
build all kinds of
things they can they can even create
computer viruses it's you know
all kinds of stuff so there's some
unknown about its utility and about
where it's going to go
but in the other hand i pointed out that
once i build a computer
it's not going to fundamentally change
how it computes
it's like i use the example of a
register which is a part internal part
of a computer
um you know i say it can't just say
because computers don't evolve
they don't replicate they don't evolve
they don't you know the physical
manifestation of the computer itself
is not gonna there's certain things it
can't do
right so we can break into things like
things that are possible to happen we
can't predict
and things are just impossible to happen
unless we go out of our way to make them
happy they're not going to happen
unless somebody makes them happen yeah
so there's there's a bunch of things to
say one is the physical
aspect which you're absolutely right we
have to build
a thing for it to operate in the
physical world and you can just stop
building them
uh you know the moment they're not doing
the thing you want them to do or just
change the design
or change the design the question is i
mean there's it's possible in the
physical world this is probably longer
term
is you automate the building it makes it
makes a lot of sense to automate the
building there's a lot of factories that
are doing more and more and more
automation
to go from raw resources to the final
product
it's possible to imagine that it's
obviously much more efficient to keep
to create a factory that's creating
robots that do something you know do
something extremely useful for society
it could be uh personal assistance it
could be uh it could be
it could be your toaster but a toaster
that's much has deeper knowledge of your
culinary preferences yeah
and and that could uh well i think now
you've hit on the right thing the real
thing we need to be worried about like
is self-replication right that is the
thing that we're in the physical world
yeah or even the virtual world
self-replication
because self-replication is dangerous
it's probably more likely to be killed
by a virus
you know or a human engineered virus
anybody can create a
you know this the technology is getting
so almost anybody well not anybody but
a lot of people could create a human
engineered virus that could wipe out
humanity
that is really dangerous no intelligence
required just self-replication
so um so we need to be careful about
that
so when i think about you know ai
i'm not thinking about robots building
robots don't do that don't build a
you know just well that's because you're
interested in creating intelligence
it seems like self-replication
is a good way to make a lot of money
well fine but
so is you know maybe editing viruses is
a good way to i don't know
the point is if as a society when we
want to look at existential risks
the existential risks we face that that
we can control
almost all evolve around
self-replication yes
the question is i don't see a good uh
way to make a lot of money by
engineering viruses and deploying them
on the world
there could be there could be
applications that are useful but let's
separate out let's separate out
i mean you don't need to you only need
some you know terrorists who wants to do
it because it doesn't take a lot of
money to make viruses
um let's just separate out what's risky
and what's not risky
i'm arguing that the intelligence side
of this equation is not risk it's not
risk it's not risky at all
it's the self-replication side of the
equation that's risky and
i'm not dismissing that i'm scared as
hell it's like the paperclip
maximizer thing yeah those are often
like
talked about in the same conversation um
i think you're right like creating ultra
intelligent super intelligent
systems is not necessarily coupled with
the self-replicating arbitrarily
self-replicating systems yeah and you
don't get evolution unless you're
self-replicating
yeah and so i think that's the gist of
this argument that people have trouble
separating those two out
they just think oh wow intelligence was
like us and look how look at the damage
we've done to this planet
like how we've you know destroyed all
these other species yeah well we
we're eight billion of us are seven
million of us now so
um i think the idea is that the the more
intelligent we're able to build systems
the more tempting
it becomes from a capitalist perspective
of creating products the more tempting
it becomes to create self uh reputation
systems
all right so let's say that's true so
does that mean we don't build
intelligent systems no that means we
regulate
we we understand the risks uh we
regulate them
yeah uh you know look there's a lot of
things we could do a society which have
some sort of financial benefit to
someone
which could do a lot of harm and we have
to learn how to regulate those things
we have to learn how to deal with those
things i will argue this i would say the
opposite election i would say
having intelligent machines at our
disposal
will actually help us in the end more
because it'll help us understand these
risks better and help us mitigate these
risks
there might be ways of saying oh well
how do we solve climate change problems
you know how do we do this or how do we
do that
um that just like computers are
dangerous in the hands of the wrong
people but they've been so great for so
many other things we live with those
dangers
and i think we have to do the same with
intelligent machines we just but we have
to be constantly vigilant about this
idea of
a bad actors doing bad things with them
and b um
don't ever ever create a
self-replicating system
and by the way i don't even know if you
could create a self-replicating system
that uses a factory that's really
dangerous you know
nature's way of self-replicating is so
amazing
um you know it doesn't require anything
it just me know
the thing and resources and it goes
right yeah um
if i said to you you know what we have
to build
our goal is to build a factory that can
make that builds new factories
and it has to end-to-end supply chain
that's the it has to
mind the resources get the energy i mean
that's really hard it's you know no
one's doing that in the next
you know 100 years i've been extremely
impressed
by the efforts of elon musk and tesla to
try to do exactly that not
not from raw resource well he actually i
think states
the goal is to go from raw resource to
the uh
the final car in one factory yeah that's
that's the main goal of course it's not
currently possible
but they're taking huge leaps well he's
not the only one to do that
this has been a goal for many uh
industries for a long long time
um it's difficult to do well a lot of
people what they do is instead they have
like
a million suppliers and then they like
there's
everybody's management they all
co-locate them and they tie the
systems together it's a fundamental
distribution
i think that's that also is not getting
at the issue i was just talking about um
which is self-replication it's
um i mean self-replication means there's
no entity involved other than the entity
that's replicating
um right and so if there's humans in
this in the loop
that's not really self-replicating right
it's unless
somehow we're duped but
it's also i i don't necessarily
agree with you because you've kind of
mentioned that ai will not say no to us
i just think they will yeah yeah so like
uh
i think it's a useful feature to build
in i'm just trying to
like uh put myself in the mind of
engineers
to sometimes say no you know if you you
yeah well i mean i gave an example
earlier right i give an example of my
car
yeah right my car turns the wheel and
and applies the accelerator and the
brake as i say until
it decides there's something dangerous
yes and then it doesn't do that
yeah now that was something
it didn't decide to do it's something we
programmed into the car
uh and so good it's a good idea right
the question again isn't like if we
create an intelligent system will it
ever
ignore our commands of course it will
sometimes is it going to do it because
it came up came up with its own
goals that serve its purposes and it
doesn't care about our purposes no i
don't think that's going to happen
you